MEANWHILE 28 MINUTES BEFORE THE
TOP OF THE HOUR.
HE TOLD YOU, SENATOR RAND PAUL,
AFTER NEWLY-RELEASED E-MAILS
SHOW A KEY WUHAN RESEARCHER
THANKED DR. FAUCI FOR DOWN
PLAYING THE CORONAVIRUS
LAB LEAK THEORY, BUT STILL, THE
PRESS WASTED NO TIME GUSHING
OVER THE E-MAIL, 3,000-PLUS.
ACTUALLY, PRAISING THEIR FRANK
HONESTY AND THE PRESSURE THAT
FELL ON ONE MAN’S SHOULDERS.
SENATOR RAND PAUL JOINS US NOW
TO REACT.
SENATOR I’VE BEEN WATCHING YOU
ALONG THE WAY AND WE ALSO
WATCHED YOUR EXCHANGE WITH DR.
FAUCI LIVE.
WHAT DO THE 3,200 E-MAILS TELL
YOU?
>> WELL THEY TELL ME THAT EARLY
ON, HE WAS VERY WORRIED.
YOU KNOW, THERE IS A DISTURBING
PICTURE, HE GETS AN E-MAIL OR
NOTIFICATION OF WHAT’S GOING ON
IN WUHAN AND HE IMMEDIATELY
SENDS SOMETHING TO HIS ASSISTANT
AN E-MAIL SAYING WE MUST MEET
IMMEDIATELY, READ THIS ARTICLE
AND IN THE SUBJECT LINE, IN THE
ARTICLE IT SAYS "GAIN OF
FUNCTION RESEARCH IN WUHAN."
WELL HE STILL DENIES, TO THIS
DAY, HE WAS FUNDING IT, AND
AS YOU KNOW, GAIN OF FUNCTION IS
WHERE YOU TAKE AN ANIMAL VIRUS
AND YOU MAKE IT INTO A SUPER-
VIRUS THAT INFECTS HUMANS.
THEY WERE DOING THIS AT THE
WUHAN LAB.
DR. FAUCI STILL DENIES IT TO
THIS DAY, BUT IN HIS PRIVATE
E-MAILS, HE PUTS IN THE SUBJECT
LINE, "URGENT, WE MUST DISCUSS
THIS GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH"
SO HE KNOWS IT’S GAIN OF
FUNCTION, AND HE NEEDS TO BE
PINNED DOWN ON THIS.
THERE ARE SCIENTISTS ACROSS
AMERICA WHO WILL DISPUTE WHAT
HE’S SAYING, WHO SAID THAT
SPECIFICALLY THE GRANT AND THE
MONEY GIVEN TO WUHAN THAT
DR. FAUCI APPROVED THAT IT WAS
GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH, AND
WE NEED TO TALK TO THESE
SCIENTISTS IN THIS FIELD AND
HEAR FROM THEM ABOUT HOW DR.
FAUCI IS NOT BEING HONEST
WITH THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
BRIAN:  JUST THE TONE OF SOME OF
THESE E-MAILS EVEN THOUGH SOME
OF THEM ARE REDACTED, SHOW THE
URGENCY BASICALLY OMG WE
BASICALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
AND SHOULD THE GUY WHOSE FUNDING
THESE LABS BE IN CHARGE OF
TELLING AMERICA HOW TO HANDLE IT
AND WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
THERE’S A DISCONNECT OF PUTTING
HIM IN CHARGE.
THAT WAS A BIG MISTAKE.
>> YEAH, SO EARLY ON, I WAS
SOMEWHAT IT’S WEIGHTED.
ALL THESE SCIENTISTS WERE
TELLING ME IT COULDN’T HAVE COME
FROM THE LAB AND I LISTENED TO
THEM BUT THEN I DISCOVERED THEY
HAD NOT REVEALED THAT THEY WERE
THE VERY SCIENTISTS THAT WERE
FUNDING THE LAB, SO THE CONFLICT
OF INTEREST IS THIS.
IF THIS VIRUS CAME FROM THE LAB,
THERE’S A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF AT
LEAST MORAL CULPABILITY TO THE
PEOPLE ADVOCATING FOR THIS.
DR. FAUCI, TO THIS DAY, SAYS HE
STILL TRUSTS THE CHINESE
SCIENTISTS.
I DON’T THINK HE SEEMS TO BE
AWARE OF THE WAY IT WORKS IN A
COMMUNIST GOVERNMENT.
DO YOU THINK THERE AREN’T
MILITARY GENERALS IN THAT LAB AS
WELL?
DO YOU THINK SOME OF THE
SCIENTISTS AREN’T ALSO IN
THE COMMUNIST PARTY AND THE
MILITARY, SO I DON’T THINK
THAT HAVING TRUST OF CHINESE
SCIENTISTS WITH GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH WAS VERY WISE, IN FACT
IT WAS SO NAIVE THAT WE
SHOULDN’T HAVE DR. FAUCI IN A
POSITION OF ADVISING THE U.S. ,
THE WORLD, OR  ANYBODY ELSE,
BECAUSE HE’S SHOWN SUCH POOR
DECISION-MAKING.
BRIAN:  I WATCHED YOU BRAWL WITH
HIM MANY TIMES BUT I THOUGHT IN
A FAIR WAY HE WOULD TRY TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS BUT THE
QUESTION WAS WAS HE TELLING
THE TRUTH ONE OF WHICH IS ON
MASKS.
YOU TOLD HIM, I’VE HAD IT
ALREADY, I HAVE THE ANTIBODIES.
WE HAVE AN E-MAIL OF HIM SAYING
CLOTH MASKS DON’T WORK TO
SOMEBODY ELSE SO HE TELLS ONE
SCIENTIST TRYING TO URGE HIM TO
TELL THE COUNTRY TO MARIAH CAREY
A WEAR A MASK, WHAT DO YOU THINK
HE THINKS?
>> IT’S A VERY DEFINITION OF
THEATRE.
IF YOU ASK HIM ABOUT IMMUNITY,
IF YOU ASK HIM PRIVATELY IF I’VE
HAD THE DISEASE DO I IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD HAVE IMMUNITY, HE’LL
SAY YES BUT THEN HE’LL SAY WE’RE
GOING TO COMPLETELY DISCOUNT IT
AND THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
PUBLIC POLICY DECISION.
IN INDIA THERE’S 1 BILLION
PEOPLE, 400,000 PEOPLE A DAY ARE
GETTING THIS.
THEY HAVE 2,000 PEOPLE A DAY
DYING AT LEAST, AND SO THERE’S A
REAL QUESTION.
SHOULD YOU GIVE THE VACCINE TO
PEOPLE WHO HAVE ALREADY HAD THE
DISEASE OR  SHOULD YOU SAVE
THE VACCINE FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVEN’T BEEN INFECTED?
THERE’S NOT ENOUGH VACCINE TO GO
AROUND IN INDIA.
THIS IS PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY OR
PUBLIC HEALTH DECISION IN THE
WORLD RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE DR.
FAUCI ISN’T BEING HONEST
ABOUT IMMUNITY, THEY MAY WELL BE
GIVING THE VACCINE TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE ALREADY INFECTED, WHICH IS
NOT ALLOWING ENOUGH PEOPLE TO
GET VACCINATED FOR THEM TO GET
TO HERD IMMUNITY.
BRIAN:  AND DR. RAND PAUL THIS
IS SOMETHING PEOPLE SHOULD
KEEP IN MIND.
IF HE HAS THE CHECKBOOK, AND
HE’S FUNDING THESE LABS, AND
THESE ARE RESEARCH THAT THE
RESEARCHERS WANT FUNDED, WHY
WOULD THEY EVER COME OUT AGAINST
HIM?
IT BE AGAINST THEIR OWN INTEREST
S, SO THIS FORMULA
DOESN’T WORK FOR AMERICA.
>> WELL, HE HAS YET TO
APOLOGIZE OR  EVEN ADMIT THAT
THEY WERE DOING GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH EVEN THOUGH HIS PRIVATE
E-MAILS ADMIT IMMEDIATELY, OH,
MY GOD GOODNESS, WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING IMMEDIATELY ABOUT THIS
GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH
SO HE ADMITS IN PRIVATE WHAT HE
WON’T SAY IN PUBLIC AND THIS IS
A BIG DEAL BECAUSE IF YOU AT
LEAST SAY HE MADE A MISTAKE
THERE MIGHT BE SOME
CONSIDERATION, BUT HE STILL
DENYING THAT WE FUNDED THE WUHAN
LAB, GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH,
OR  THAT THEY WERE DOING IT OR
THAT IT WAS AN UNWISE DECISION.
THERE’S A BIGGER DECISION ALSO,
BRIAN.
WE HAVE 11 LABS IN THE UNITED
STATES, DOING GAIN OF FUNCTION.
I DON’T GIVE OUR RESEARCHERS BAD
MOTIVES I THINK OUR RESEARCHERS
ARE GOOD PEOPLE, BUT I WORRY
ABOUT THE IDEA OF WHETHER WE
SHOULD TAKE THE SPANISH FLU AND
TRY TO TRANSMIT IT AND MAKE IT
EASIER TO INFECT WITH HUMANS
WHETHER THAT’S A GOOD IDEA AND
WHETHER IT COULD POSSIBLY ESCAPE
IN THE U.S. AS WELL, SO THIS
RESEARCH MANY MANY
SCIENTISTS, NOT JUST PEOPLE IN
THE POLITICAL WORLD, BUT MANY
SCIENTISTS ARE VERY VERY WEARY
OF THIS AND WHILE GOING TO TRY
TO HAVE A HEARING IN WASHINGTON,
I DON’T THINK THE DEMOCRATS WILL
ALLOW US TO DO IT OFFICIALLY BUT
I’LL TRY TO HAVE AN OPEN
DISCUSSION IN THE CAPITOL
BRINGING IN THE SCIENTISTS WHO
DISCUSS AND ARE WORRIED ABOUT
GAIN OF FUNCTION.
MOST OF THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT
PARTISANS, THEY AREN’T
REPUBLICANS OR  DEMOCRATS THEY
ARE JUST SCIENTISTS BUT
IMPARTIAL SCIENTISTS WORRIED
ABOUT THIS FOR A DECADE THAT
THIS COULD HAPPEN.
BRIAN:  YEAH, ACTUALLY, WHAT YOU
BROUGHT UP IS NOT PARTISAN
EITHER.
I THINK WE’RE ALL AGAINST THE
CORONAVIRUS AND STOPPING THE
NEXT ONE AND YOU’VE BEEN
THERE FIRST, FIRE FAUCI I KNOW
EXACTLY HOW YOU FEEL GOING INTO
THE SEGMENT AND I DON’T THINK
YOU’VE CHANGED YOUR MIND DURING.
SENATOR RAND PAUL THANKS FOR